قد تكون ممن ينتظرون اكتشاف العلماء
لاكسير الشباب الذي يمنحك نشاطا ويزيل
تجاعيد من البشره لكن هناك رجل لا ينتظر
هذا اليوم بل بدا بعكس مسار حياته محاولا
اطاله عمره بواسطه تجربه فريده يجريها على
نفسه لاثبات انه يمكن ابطاء الشيخوخه التي
تصيب البشر
هو رجل الاعمال براين جونسون الذي يعتقد
ان تجربته ناجحه وتؤتي ثمارها يقول انه
تمكن من عكس عمره بمعدل خمس سنوات تقريبا
خلال سبعه اشهر ويامل في تحسين جوده جلده
ليكون مثل جلد شاب صغير بعمر 18 عاما
وبفضل ممارسه التمرينات الرياضيه بانتظام
انخفضت نسبه الدهون في جسمه الى 5%
[موسيقى]
وطبعا ثمن العوده للشباب مرتفع جدا فتجربه
جونسون الاربعيني مكلفه للغايه حيث ينفق
نحو مليوني دولار سنويا على العلاجات
والمكملات ومئات الاختبارات
ويراقبه فريق طبي بانتظام اضافه لمئات
الفحوصات ويحدث كل هذا في بيته المكتظ
بالمعدات الطبيه باهظه الثمن في لوس
انجلوس لهذا باع شركته المتخصصه في انظمه
الدفع الالكتروني عام 2013 مقابل 800
مليون دولار ليستثمر في هذا المشروع
اما خطته للعوده للشباب يتبع فيها جونسون
خطوات مرسومه بدقه تشمل كل شيء سواء نظام
غذائي صارم وممارسه التمرينات الرياضيه
الى تناول عشرات المكملات الغذائيه ويقول
انه يتناول حوالي 30 كيلو جراما من
الخضروات شهريا ونحو اثنتين وخمسين حبه
دواء في الصباح يوميا
[موسيقى]